Sean, hey, you're feeling kind of sleepy. I am. You're feeling a little bit drowsy. I am. And you're listening to my voice. Oh, this is crazy. And when I say three, two, one, you're under my control, Sean. Okay, I don't believe this would work, but let's try it. I hate tuna sandwiches. Say I hate tuna sandwiches. I hate tuna sandwiches. You didn't say three, two, one. Oh, did I not say three, two, one? God, I make a terrible hypnotist. Welcome to smart list. Smart. Smart. Well, you just recently moved out of your house. Yeah, I did. Yeah. So listener, so we'll, we'll have moved out of his house, but he still has a recording booth there in the house because he does make a grip on voiceover work. And so he's asked this new owner if he can come in and use his audio studio.
肖恩，嘿，你感觉有点困了。我是。你感觉有点昏昏欲睡。我是。你在听我的声音。哦，这太疯狂了。当我数到三、二、一，你就受我控制了，肖恩。好吧，我不相信这会奏效，但我们试试吧。我讨厌金枪鱼三明治。说我讨厌金枪鱼三明治。我讨厌金枪鱼三明治。你没数三、二、一。哦，我没数三、二、一吗？天哪，我真是个糟糕的催眠师。欢迎来到Smartless。Smart。Smart。好吧，你最近刚搬出你的房子。是的，我搬了。是的。所以听众们，威尔，威尔已经搬出了他的房子，但他仍然在房子里有一个录音棚，因为他确实做了很多配音工作。所以他问了这位新房主，他是否可以进来使用他的音频工作室。
That is hilarious. Wait, so it's different families living there right now, but you're in there with them? Yeah, I just met the new owners as I came up and they let me and they agreed to for the next week, let me continue to use the, what I call my booth is technically their booth. You're joking, right? But you're watching people living in your kitchen as of last week was your kitchen, your living room, everything. I just met them in, in what is now their kitchen. I don't know how do you deal with that? Well, luckily I'm very cut off emotionally. So I don't, you know, I don't let that, but it was very strange. Like they open the door, come on in, into a house. I built this house, as you know. Well, a crane, a crane did, a container
那太搞笑了。等等，所以现在是不同的家庭住在那里，但你和他们在一起？是的，我刚上来时遇到了新房主，他们同意在接下来的一周里，让我继续使用我称之为我的录音棚，实际上是他们的录音棚。你在开玩笑吧？但你看着人们住在你的厨房里，上周那还是你的厨房、你的客厅，一切都是。我刚在现在是他们厨房的地方遇到了他们。我不知道你是怎么处理的？好吧，幸运的是，我在情感上非常冷漠。所以我不会，你知道，我不会让那种情绪影响我，但这非常奇怪。就像他们打开门，进来吧，进到一栋房子里。你知道，这房子是我建的。好吧，起重机，起重机建的，集装箱
crane did. Oh yeah, don't get Kimmel started on me building this. You know, Sean, his house is one of those kind of new fancy modern, we're just going to stack a bunch of glass boxes on each other. Oh yeah, no, I saw it. It's like a Costco. Prefab. I went shopping in there. It's a beautiful house. It was on the cover of Dwell Mag. I don't need to sell it anymore. I already sold it. Yeah, you did. But it's any of your, any of your personal things still there that they're rummaging through or just, just in this, it's like I'm in the Vatican, you know, like I'm just, I've got this little oasis here, this little temple inside their house. And I did, I will admit this, I came up here and they were like, you can use, you know, they're, by the way, these people are so nice and so,
起重机建的。哦，是的，别让吉梅尔开始谈论我盖房子的事。你知道，肖恩，他的房子是那种新的时髦现代风格，我们只是要把一堆玻璃盒子堆在一起。哦，是的，不，我看到了。就像好市多（Costco）的预制件。我在里面逛过。那是一栋漂亮的房子。它曾登上《Dwell》杂志的封面。我不需要再卖它了。我已经卖掉了。是的，你卖了。但你还有什么私人物品留在那里让他们翻找吗，还是只是，只是在这个，就像我在梵蒂冈一样，你知道，就像我在这里有一个小绿洲，在他们房子里的一个小神殿。我得承认，我上来的时候，他们就像，你可以使用，你知道，顺便说一句，这些人太好了，太
so sweet. And they said, yeah, feel free to use it the next week. Don't all good. And then I get in here and their dancers and the kids are like, I really got to take a leak. Like I wonder if they'll know if I just pop around the corner and I did, I popped around like tiptoeing around in what one week ago was my house. That's so crazy. Tiptoeing in to take a leak. It was very, it's very odd, but I will say the kindness, it reaffirmed my faith in humanity. These people are very sweet to let me continue to do this. That's nice. So I'm very nervous. I know that you have heard me introduce guests before by saying today's guest is going to really class us up, but today it has never been more true. I have been an admirer of this man for as long as I have been
太贴心了。他们说，是的，下周尽管用吧。没问题。然后我进来了，他们的舞者和孩子们就像，我真的得去撒个尿。我想知道如果我溜到拐角处他们会知道吗，我确实这么做了，我溜了过去，就像在这一周前还是我房子的房子里踮着脚走。这太疯狂了。踮着脚去撒尿。这非常，非常奇怪，但我得说，这种善意，重申了我对人性的信念。这些人非常贴心，让我继续这样做。那很好。所以我很紧张。我知道你们以前听过我介绍嘉宾，说今天的嘉宾真的会提升我们的档次，但今天这句话从未如此真实。我崇拜这个人，就像我一直以来
smart enough to admire smart people, which is sadly only the second half of my life. This man is one, among other wards, the Pulitzer Prize and the George Polk. Okay. He, he started his career in journalism at the Washington Post in 1982. He covered Metro sports style. Then in 1988, he became their Moscow correspondent. I'm not smart enough. This is in 1992. He became a staff writer at the New Yorker and a short six years later was named editor, a position he remains in to this day. You got it. You can only one of five people to hold that title in the magazine's 100 year history. He's one of our smartest and most cultured thinkers that we have today. And I have zero idea why I said yes to the big swing that took
聪明到足以崇拜聪明人一样，遗憾的是这只是我人生的后半段。这个人，除其他奖项外，还获得了普利策奖和乔治·波尔克奖。好吧。他，他1982年在《华盛顿邮报》开始了新闻生涯。他报道过都市、体育、时尚。然后在1988年，他成为了他们的莫斯科通讯员。我不够聪明。这是在1992年。他成为了《纽约客》的特约撰稿人，短短六年内就被任命为编辑，这个职位他至今仍担任。你做到了。在杂志100年的历史中，只有五个人担任过这个头衔。他是我们今天最聪明、最有文化的思想家之一。我完全不知道为什么我答应了那个大胆的邀请
when I asked him to join us. Friends, please welcome Mr. David Remnick. David? Oh my gosh, David Remnick. No way. Oh, there he is. Look at this. Wow. Wait, David, you look so young to be only one of five editors in the history of the New Yorker. Is that true? I'm not the only one. No, no, no. Some die off and some retire. Yeah, but I'm just saying like five, but that's 25 years or something. It's kind of incredible. We've been around for 90, what is it, 95 years or something. And the first two, Harold Ross went for 25 years or so and William Shawn for 30 odd years, 35 years or something. David, how long have you been editor? 23 years. Wow. Geez, that's what I'm saying. Older than any pair of khakis that any of you have. Sure.
当我请他加入我们时。朋友们，请欢迎大卫·雷姆尼克先生。大卫？天哪，大卫·雷姆尼克。不会吧。哦，他就在那儿。看看这个。哇。等等，大卫，你看起来太年轻了，竟然是《纽约客》历史上仅有的五位编辑之一。是真的吗？我不是唯一一个。不，不，不。有些人去世了，有些人退休了。是的，但我只是说像五个，但这大概是25年左右。这真是不可思议。我们已经存在了90，是多少，95年左右。前两位，哈罗德·罗斯做了25年左右，威廉·肖恩做了30多年，35年左右。大卫，你当编辑多久了？23年。哇。天哪，这就是我说的。比你们任何人的卡其裤都要老。当然。
You can put some mileage on khakis because they really don't fade in any sort of substantial way. So I'm going to get right into the New Yorker and in my own subscription and my battle with my subscription with the New Yorker for many years, which is the shame I would feel when I'd be like, well, first of all, the victory I would feel when I'd read an entire issue. And then the shame I go away and I get behind and then they pile up and then I have on my counter, you know, sort of north of 40 and I'd be like, I'm going to get, okay, I got to get to that. Now I got to get to that. And then I would ultimately have to put them in the recycling and I think I never got to all 10 of these. Throwing away all that knowledge. This is our
你可以在卡其裤上留下一些磨损，因为它们真的不会以任何实质性的方式褪色。所以我要直接谈谈《纽约客》以及我多年来与《纽约客》订阅的斗争，那就是当我读完一整期时我会感到的羞耻，好吧，首先是胜利感。然后羞耻感来了，我落后了，它们堆积起来，然后我在柜台上，你知道，大概有40多本，我会想，我要去，好吧，我得去读那个。现在我得去读那个。然后我最终不得不把它们放进回收箱，我想我从来没有读完这10本中的任何一本。扔掉了所有的知识。这是我们的
editorial, this is our highest editorial aspiration, number one, to make you feel really bad. Terrible. Always. And number two, to feed the recycling. So I feed the recycling and keep the subscription, which is now, now here's how I figured it out. Now I'm on a digital. Yeah, there you go. Yeah. So I'm now on the digital slick, very slick, but I have the New Yorker is one of the, of course, I mean, but you guys should talk. I think Netflix rolls over too. I don't notice like myself getting a bill in the mail from Netflix. So, you know, yeah, yeah. Well, we're all on the same deal. Sure. Now, David, there's, there's no way that you can read every issue cover to cover. Yeah, I don't have to make a TV show or, or anything else. This is,
编辑，这是我们最高的编辑愿望，第一，让你感觉非常糟糕。糟糕。总是这样。第二，喂给回收箱。所以我喂给回收箱并保留订阅，现在，这是我弄明白的方法。我现在用数字版了。是的，就是这样。是的，所以我现在用数字版，非常时髦，非常时髦，但我有《纽约客》是其中之一，当然，我的意思是，但你们应该谈谈。我想Netflix也会自动续订。我没注意到像我自己收到Netflix寄来的账单。所以，你知道，是的，是的。好吧，我们都一样。当然。现在，大卫，你不可能每期都从头读到尾。是的，我不必制作电视节目，或者其他任何事情。这就是，
this is what I do. In fact, no kidding around. That's the great pleasure is to read the stuff. And I read it multiple times. And in addition to the thing you get in the mail or, or the, what's known as the issue, the weekly issue, we also publish a whole bunch of things every day online on New Yorker.com. So it's, the reading is increased. Yeah. So David, when you, when you started, so you started as a journalist, I imagine, what, what was your trajectory? You, you had a, you had an illustrious, uh, academic career. Well, I, since, since it was denied to me playing second base for the Yankees or being a supermodel, that's what I wanted to do. Same. I, I, I, one of those, I don't know about you guys, but once in a while you meet somebody who ended up doing exactly
这就是我所做的。事实上，不开玩笑。最大的乐趣就是阅读这些内容。我读了好几遍。除了你收到的邮件，或者，所谓的期刊，每周一期，我们每天还在NewYorker.com上发布很多东西。所以，阅读量增加了。是的。所以大卫，当你，当你开始时，所以你以记者的身份开始，我想，什么，你的轨迹是什么？你，你有一个，你有一个辉煌的，呃，学术生涯。好吧，我，因为，既然我被拒绝为洋基队打二垒或成为超级名模，那就是我想做的。一样。我，我，我，你们中不知道，但偶尔你会遇到一个最终做了完全
what they wanted to do since they were a kid. And I went in high school, we had a, a, a high school newspaper and I went to a place called Pascac Valley in the mascot. And it's a terrible word to use. Now mascot is the Indians and the newspaper was called, wait for it, the smoke signal. And no one was interested in this newspaper except for me. And I used to write, I don't know, two thirds of it using fake names and so on and do it on my kitchen table in the days when you, you know, printed these things out and cut them in columns and pasted it. And I knew I wanted to do this. I loved, I loved the idea of going out into the world and in a sense hiding behind a notebook. In other words, engaging with the world, but having a kind of purpose
他们从小就想做的事情的人。我在高中时，我们有一份高中校报，我去了一个叫帕斯卡克谷的地方，吉祥物。现在用这个词很糟糕。吉祥物是印第安人，报纸叫，等着瞧，烟雾信号。除了我之外，没人对这份报纸感兴趣。我过去常常写，我不知道，三分之二的内容，用假名等等，在我的厨房桌子上做，在那些日子里，你知道，你把这些东西打印出来，剪成栏目并粘贴。我知道我想做这个。我喜欢，我喜欢走进世界，在某种意义上躲在笔记本后面的想法。换句话说，与世界互动，但有一种目的
and come back with your, your material and, and make something of it. That, that seemed like an exciting thing to do. And nobody, nobody that my parents knew did such a thing, considered such a thing. It wasn't, my parents thought that was, this was insane, insane. Was the draw to that more a, just a simple dry reporting of the facts of news or were you confident enough, interested enough at that age to, to weave in some opinion, some, to sort of editorialize. I wasn't that sophisticated. I was a kid and, and, but it gave me the, you know, I grew up in a really boring town, kind of Springsteen North, that kind of really dull. And it was with no ocean and, in close to New York, but, but a million miles away. So everything that was exciting was across
并带着你的材料回来，并从中做出一些东西。那，那似乎是一件令人兴奋的事情。而且我父母认识的人中没有人做过这样的事，考虑过这样的事。这不是，我父母认为那是，这太疯狂了，疯狂。吸引力更多是简单的、枯燥的新闻事实报道，还是你在那个年纪已经足够自信、足够感兴趣，可以编织一些观点，一些，某种程度上进行社论化。我没那么老练。我还是个孩子，而且，但这给了我，你知道，我在一个非常无聊的城镇长大，有点像北方的斯普林斯汀，那种非常沉闷的。而且没有海洋，而且，离纽约很近，但，却远在天边。所以一切令人兴奋的事情都在
the river. The world seemed to be across the river. And so how do you get to that? And I didn't come from an incredibly sophisticated or intellectual family. I came from a family though that had, you were meant to aspire. Yeah. Right. What did your parents do, David? My father was a, had a very small dental practice and, and to be, you know, perfectly glum about it. My, my mother was six. She had MS. And eventually my father lost his dental practice because he had Parkinson's. You don't want a Parkinsonian dentist unless you want Buster Keaton as your dentist. You can get a deal. You can get a really good deal. I can, I can show you the paper. And so it was a, it was a difficult situation. Yeah. And they wanted me to do something
河对岸。世界似乎在河对岸。那么你如何到达那里呢？我不是来自一个非常老练或知识渊博的家庭。不过我来自一个家庭，你注定要追求。是的。对吧。你父母是做什么的，大卫？我父亲有一个非常小的牙科诊所，而且，你知道，对此感到非常沮丧。我母亲六岁时。她患有多发性硬化症。最终我父亲失去了他的牙科诊所，因为他患有帕金森症。你不会想要一个帕金森症牙医，除非你想要巴斯特·基顿做你的牙医。你可以得到一笔交易。你可以得到一个非常好的交易。我可以，我可以给你看报纸。所以这是一个，这是一个困难的情况。是的。他们想让我做一些
incredibly secure, be a lawyer or a doctor. That, that was the range of it. Was that the attraction to reading though, the sort of that escapism, getting into a book? Yeah. Or all of it, radio, TV, radio in those days when I was a kid and I'm older than you guys was. You don't look at David. Look at you. Look how hydrated. And so I would listen to these, obviously rock and roll was in the air, but also there were weird radio stations like Pacific or radio stations and you would kind of, the counterculture would come in by listening to it at two o'clock in the morning as a adolescent, you know, couldn't sleep. So it was excitement, but it was over there. And somehow the idea that journalism would get you
令人难以置信的安全的事情，成为一名律师或医生。那，那是范围。不过，阅读的吸引力在于那种逃避现实，进入一本书吗？是的，或者所有这些，广播，电视，广播在那些日子里，当我还是个孩子时，我比你们大。你看大卫。看看你。看看你多水润。所以我过去常常听这些，显然摇滚乐在空气中，但也有奇怪的广播电台，像太平洋广播电台，你会有点，反主流文化会通过在凌晨两点作为一个青少年听它而进来，你知道，睡不着。所以那是兴奋，但它在另一边。不知何故，新闻业会让你
over there. Get you over there. And, but would there kind of to what Jason was saying about the reading, do you suspect that there was, whether you were writing or you were editing the school paper, was there, was there a part of you maybe now, have you ever thought about the idea that you were recreating by observing other lives and actually by, you know, putting together this newspaper, you were creating a life or a world that was different from the world you were existing at the moment. I think that's right on the money. That's right on the money. And I also didn't, it was not given to me to have the self-confidence or to live in a world where people were artists. My parents knew people who sold things or fixed things or ran a store or something like that.
到那边去。到那边去。但是，对于杰森所说的关于阅读的内容，你是否怀疑，无论你是写作还是编辑校报，是否有一部分你，也许现在，你有没有想过这样一个想法，即你通过观察他人的生活，实际上通过，你知道，把这份报纸放在一起，你正在创造一个与你当时存在的世界不同的生活或世界。我认为这完全正确。这完全正确。而且我也没有，我没有自信或生活在一个人们是艺术家的世界里。我父母认识的人是卖东西或修理东西或经营商店或类似的事情。
The idea that somebody would be an artist was preposterous and laughable and just otherworldly. So a journalist seemed like a middle ground. Do you know what I mean? You could make a living at, there was a job that you could occupy, you could work at a newspaper or something like that. Right. And a proximity to the artist, but also another foot firmly in sort of establishment. Yeah. I knew from a very young age in some intuitive way that I would have to make some sort of living to, quite frankly, to support them much less myself. Right. And that's what ended up being the case. You know, Duddy Kravitz, the apprenticeship at Duddy Kravitz. I know it all too well. It's so good in that great line of like, a man is nothing unless he owns land,
有人会成为艺术家的想法是荒谬的、可笑的，简直是超凡脱俗的。所以记者似乎是一个中间地带。你知道我的意思吗？你可以以此为生，有一份你可以从事的工作，你可以在报纸上工作或类似的事情。对。而且与艺术家接近，但另一只脚也坚定地站在某种体制内。是的。我从很小的时候就直觉地知道，我必须以某种方式谋生，坦率地说，为了支持他们，更不用说我自己了。对。而这最终就是事实。你知道，杜迪·克拉维茨，杜迪·克拉维茨的学徒生涯。我太了解了。那句伟大的台词太棒了，比如，一个人如果不拥有土地就什么都不是，
like that thing, like you have to do something, you have to own land, you have to do. Well, I just had to make sure that they somehow got to the end of their lives. You know, we don't hate to turn all terribly serious on you, but we live in a political system where if you are weak or sick or left behind, you're in deep trouble. Whether it's about health insurance or it's about a minimum amount of income or whatever. And I could see that coming like a freight train. Yeah. You started it. So this is where I want to go. And we can lighten it up as we go through it. If we want to. But we're going to go darker. I want to use your brain for a second here. So I mean, I know that there's no solid answer for this, but I would love your
就像那样，就像你必须做点什么，你必须拥有土地，你必须做。好吧，我只是必须确保他们以某种方式走到了生命的尽头。你知道，我们不想在你面前变得太严肃，但我们生活在一个政治体系中，如果你软弱或生病或被抛在后面，你就会陷入大麻烦。无论是关于健康保险还是关于最低收入或任何其他事情。我可以看到它像货运列车一样驶来。是的。你开始了。所以这就是我想去的地方。我们可以随着我们的进行让它变得轻松。如果我们想的话。但我们要去更黑暗的地方。我想用你的大脑一秒钟。所以我的意思是，我知道对此没有确切的答案，但我很想听听你的
perspective on, in your gut, do you think that we are now currently in a period nationally that is temporary, you know, an anomaly that will make for interesting retrospection? Or do you think that we are in potentially the first chapter of what may be an endless story about two tribes without a happy ending potentially? I mean, if we're going to, let's ruin everybody's mood right away. Let's just kill it. Let's just. Yeah, it's a good idea. Yeah. Well, because then it's only up from there. Exactly. It's kind of a rhythmic thing. Yeah. It's never going to get more glum than this listener. What we've just gone through this year and a half is a rehearsal, a rehearsal, the pandemic is a rehearsal, not just for other
观点，从你的直觉来看，你认为我们现在正处于一个全国性的时期，是暂时的，你知道，一个会产生有趣回顾的异常现象吗？还是你认为我们可能正处于一个关于两个部落没有幸福结局的无尽故事的第一章？我的意思是，如果我们打算，让我们立刻毁掉每个人的心情。让我们杀了它。让我们。是的，这是个好主意。是的。好吧，因为那样的话，只有从那里往上走。正是如此。这是一种有节奏的事情。是的，听众们，这永远不会比这更沉闷了。我们过去一年半经历的事情是一次排练，一次排练，大流行是一次排练，不仅是为了其他
pandemics, but for really for climate change. And if we don't get our shit together politically, environmentally, we are going to face something that there's no vaccine for. Right. There's no vaccine for that's number one. Number two, we're living in a period where we're playing very fast and loose with the greatest gift we've had. This is a country that had the great gift, despite all its problems and slavery and so much more of a period of enlightenment, philosophers who gave us something called liberal democratic society. Yeah. And we are in the process of willy-nilly seeing it being thrown out the window by the, I think we can go into that if you want at some point, or we can talk about the cartoons in the New Yorker. Well, no, no, no,
大流行，而且实际上是为了气候变化。如果我们不在政治上、环境上把我们的事情搞定，我们将面临一些没有疫苗的东西。对。没有疫苗，这是第一点。第二，我们生活在一个我们正在非常草率地对待我们拥有的最伟大礼物的时期。这是一个拥有伟大礼物的国家，尽管它有所有的问题和奴隶制以及更多，一个启蒙时期，哲学家们给了我们一种叫做自由民主社会的东西。是的。我们正在随意地看着它被扔出窗外，我想如果我们愿意，我们可以在某个时候深入探讨这一点，或者我们可以谈谈《纽约客》里的漫画。好吧，不，不，不，
I don't want to talk about it. And, and, and, and, and I think that we're in a moment also of racial reckoning that's long and coming or it's happened every so often, but now it's at its next stage. That's extremely serious. So that's just three big things. And isn't it interesting though, because I always whenever I hear, you know, I'm, I'm a news junkie just as much as the other person until I realize I can't do anything about any of it except vote. And that's what really is. Yeah, I don't think that's true. It's like, yeah, oh my God, it's so frustrating. Sure, we can go out and protest. We can do these things, but we don't, all we have the power to do is vote. Otherwise, we're just filled with anger all day long. I think you also have the power to
我不想谈论它。而且，而且，而且，而且我认为我们正处于一个种族清算的时刻，这已经很久了，或者它每隔一段时间就会发生，但现在它处于下一个阶段。这极其严重。所以这只是三件大事。而且这难道不有趣吗，因为我总是，每当我听到，你知道，我是一个新闻迷，就像其他人一样，直到我意识到除了投票我什么都做不了。而这才是真正的。是的，我不认为那是真的。就像，是的，天哪，这太令人沮丧了。当然，我们可以出去抗议。我们可以做这些事情，但我们不，我们唯一有权做的事情就是投票。否则，我们整天都充满了愤怒。我认为你也有权力
make art. Yeah. To, to protest. For sure. To be funny in ways that are provocative. Thank you. I have no illusion that the New Yorker, which has a, you know, a circulation of a million, three, and then maybe four or five million people read it. I have no illusion that this is going to, you know, be a conversion experience throughout the United States must lessen, you know, red America. I'm not deluded, but each person, each in their own way can play some kind of role. That's what, that's what the whole thing is about anyway in large measure. And if you give into resignation or give up the game each in your own way, then, then maybe we didn't deserve it in the first place. And now back to the show. So, you know, somebody in the New Yorker who I really
创作艺术。是的。去抗议。当然。以挑衅的方式变得有趣。谢谢。我没有幻想《纽约客》，它有，你知道，130万的发行量，然后可能有四五百万人阅读它。我没有幻想这会，你知道，成为整个美国的皈依体验，更不用说，你知道，红色美国了。我没有被迷惑，但每个人，每个人以自己的方式都可以扮演某种角色。无论如何，这在很大程度上就是整个事情的意义所在。如果你屈服于辞职或以自己的方式放弃游戏，那么，那么也许我们一开始就不配得到它。现在回到节目。所以，你知道，在《纽约客》里，我真的很
enjoy who plays around with a lot of the themes that we talk about, but in a really delightful way is Andy Borowitz and the Borowitz report. Can you talk a little bit, did he predate your becoming editor of the New Yorker? You know, so Andy, you know, Andy's career. Did he create the Fresh Prince of Bel Air? So my understanding is he met, he was at the Harvard Lampoon. Right. And I think he either met Bud Yorken or Norman Lee or somebody like that through that high office. And he wrote a treatment for or some kernel of what became the Fresh Prince of Bel Air eventually. And, you know, which by the way, I think pays better than freelance writing and creating a TV show in the nineties. Yeah. Yeah. Lots of episodes. We're not throwing a benefit for Andy any time
喜欢，他玩弄了很多我们谈论的主题，但以一种非常令人愉快的方式，是安迪·博罗维茨和博罗维茨报告。你能谈谈吗，他在你成为《纽约客》编辑之前吗？你知道，所以安迪，你知道，安迪的职业生涯。他创造了《新鲜王子妙事多》吗？所以我的理解是他遇到了，他在哈佛讽刺文集。对。我想他通过那个高级办公室遇到了巴德·约肯或诺曼·李或类似的人。他写了一个治疗方案，或者后来成为《新鲜王子妙事多》的核心。而且，你知道，顺便说一句，我认为这比自由撰稿和在九十年代创作电视节目报酬更高。是的。是的。很多剧集。我们不会很快为安迪举办福利活动
soon. Well, I would never ask him, but what is it? You have to go over a hundred episodes and then it's just the time anymore. Nobody cares. So and I think Andy, you know, is able, like the onion and like a lot of our best comedians are able to see the absolute absurdity in political life. And he does it through this headline form. And he's pretty hilarious. Yeah. He's hilarious. I find it it's so delightful. And I find it to be so, we kind of brought him, he had his own gig online and we kind of brought him into the New Yorker. He was always at the around the New Yorker. He was doing things for the New Yorker, but the constancy was brought from his, I guess, what used to be called a blog and and then brought on. Right. So, so, so now that we're still on the New Yorker,
很快。好吧，我永远不会问他，但那是什么？你必须超过一百集，然后就只是时间问题了。没人关心。所以我想安迪，你知道，能够，像洋葱新闻和我们许多最好的喜剧演员一样，能够看到政治生活中绝对的荒谬。他通过这种标题形式来做到这一点。而且他非常搞笑。是的。他很搞笑。我发现它非常令人愉快。而且我发现它非常，我们有点把他带进来了，他在网上有自己的演出，我们有点把他带进了《纽约客》。他一直都在《纽约客》周围。他一直在为《纽约客》做事情，但这种恒常性是从他的，我猜，过去被称为博客的东西带来的，然后被带进来了。对。所以，所以，所以现在我们还在《纽约客》上，
the other thing I want to ask you, because this is really important, and I want to ask you, David, first, and then I'm going to go around to the fellas. And you have to be honest. And I know that you have a lot of, you're going to have a lot of favorites. It's kind of like asking, well, who's your favorite child? Favorite New Yorker cartoon of all time. What, what is it? Describe it, please. Oh, ask those guys first and I'll think. Okay. Okay. Sean or Jason. Okay, I got it. I got it. Oh, wait, wait, sorry. Yeah, Sean and Jason. All right. So you're on eyes again. And it's completely self-involved and it involves a gift. So I think one of the great comic geniuses in the country of any kind is Ross Chast. You guys know Ross Chast and
另一件事我想问你，因为这真的很重要，我想先问你，大卫，然后我要去问伙计们。你必须诚实。我知道你有很多，你会有很多最爱。这有点像问，好吧，谁是你最喜欢的孩子？有史以来最喜欢的《纽约客》漫画。什么，它是什么？请描述一下。哦，先问那些家伙，我会想的。好的。好的。肖恩或杰森。好的，我明白了。哦，等等，等等，抱歉。是的，肖恩和杰森。好吧。所以你又在盯着看了。而且它完全是自我参与的，并且涉及一份礼物。所以我认为全国任何一种最伟大的漫画天才之一是罗斯·查斯特。你们认识罗斯·查斯特和
she has this kind of wobbly line and her humor comes out of, you know, Brooklyn neurotic, old parents who are school teachers. And when I turned 40, which I love to admit it was some time ago, I was feeling pretty, I don't know how you guys turned 40. Yes, right? Yeah. Yeah. It's not the best day of your life. I currently play 38. Yeah. What was the question? Jack Benny. And I contrived some reason to stay home from work that day. And yet this thing came in the, in, you know, was delivered to the house, a big framed thing. And it was Ross Chast had delivered or the office had delivered or gotten me this strip that Ross had done about her childhood and her obsession with Charles Adams, who was one of the great New Yorker cartoonists.
她有这种摇摇晃晃的线条，她的幽默来自于，你知道，布鲁克林神经质的、当老师的老父母。当我四十岁时，我喜欢承认那是很久以前的事了，我感觉相当，我不知道你们是怎么四十岁的。是的，对吧？是的。是的。这不是你一生中最美好的一天。我目前扮演38岁。是的。问题是什么？杰克·本尼。那天我编造了一些理由留在家里不去上班。然而这东西进来了，在，你知道，被送到家里，一个大的框架东西。那是罗斯·查斯特送来的，或者办公室送来的，或者给我弄到了这张罗斯做的关于她童年的连环画，以及她对查尔斯·亚当斯的痴迷，他是《纽约客》最伟大的漫画家之一。
And so that, that strip hangs in my apartment. And so I have to give that pride of place. Yeah. Yeah. She, she, she has very distinctive, a very distinctive style, Ross Chast. She sure does. Yeah. Very, very cool. Very funny. Sean, do you have one? No, I don't read. The New Yorker cartoons? Jason, hang on, hang on. We're still doing this. One sentence at a time. Jason, do you have one? I'm embarrassed to say that I just read the articles and not even as often as I would like to. I do not spend time with the cartoons. Well, get to it. I was teeing myself up. I was teeing myself. Okay, go ahead. Good. Keep in mind the title of the, of this show is called Smartlers. Go ahead. Right. My favorite New Yorker cartoon, of which I have two framed versions,
所以那张连环画挂在我的公寓里。所以我必须给它优先地位。是的。是的。她，她，她有非常独特的，非常独特的风格，罗斯·查斯特。她确实有。是的。非常，非常酷。非常有趣。肖恩，你有一个吗？不，我不读。《纽约客》漫画？杰森，等等，等等。我们还在做这个。一次一句。杰森，你有一个吗？我很尴尬地说我只读文章，甚至不像我希望的那样频繁。我不花时间看漫画。好吧，开始吧。我正在为自己做准备。我正在为自己做准备。好吧，继续。好的。记住这个节目的标题叫Smartless。继续。对。我最喜欢的《纽约客》漫画，我有两个装裱版本，
because two people knew I loved it so much, they gave it to me as gifts is the, the, the, the image is a piece of penne. Do you know what I'm getting at? It's a piece of penne pasta and he's on the phone. He's picked up the phone and he's saying, Fusilli, you crazy bastard. How the hell are you? It looks better than it sounds. It's incredible. It's Charles Barsotti is the, is the cartoonist. I remember it well. I remember it well. It's incredible. To me, it's the funniest joke of all time. Well, you know the process, how they do this. I mean, maybe it's, I guess it's the individual version of a writer's room is that these guys, and then it's no thank God, it's no longer all guys. It's much more diverse in all ways in, in, in recent years, which is the achievement in many
因为两个人知道我太喜欢它了，他们把它作为礼物送给了我，图像是一块通心粉。你知道我在说什么吗？那是一块通心粉，他在打电话。他拿起电话说，Fusilli，你这个疯狂的混蛋。你他妈的怎么样？它看起来比听起来好。这太不可思议了。查尔斯·巴索蒂是漫画家。我记得很清楚。我记得很清楚。这太不可思议了。对我来说，这是有史以来最有趣的笑话。好吧，你知道他们做这个的过程。我的意思是，也许是，我猜这是作家室的个人版本，就是这些家伙，而且谢天谢地，不再全是男人了。近年来，它在各方面都更加多样化，这是艾玛·艾伦的成就，她是过去几年的漫画编辑，你知道，艺术家们独自在家，他们做所谓的草稿，你知道，某种草稿版本的绘画，他们只是做想法和想法和想法，然后他们把它们寄进来，你知道，一周六个，一周十个，无论多少。漫画编辑翻阅巨大的堆栈，然后一周有一天甚至有一个会议，人们进来，就像进到一个，你知道，急诊室或类似的地方。一个接一个地来看艾玛，他们讨论它，她把堆栈削减到大约，我不知道，50或60个。然后我和她翻阅它，我们挑选20个。这相当残酷。这非常艰难。那很艰难。你有没有不得不取消一个
ways of Emma Allen, the cartoon editor for the past several years is, you know, the artists are at home all by their lonesome and they do what's called roughs, you know, kind of a rough version of the drawing and they just do ideas and ideas and ideas and then they send them in, you know, six a week, 10 a week, however many. And the cartoon editor goes through the huge stack and then one day a week even has a meeting and the people come in like into a, you know, an emergency room or something. And one after another comes to see Emma and they talk it through and she whittles down the stack to about, I don't know, 50 or 60. And then she and I go through it and we pick 20. It's pretty brutal. It's very tough. That's tough. Have you ever had to disqualify one
你后悔的，你觉得，哦，有什么东西让你觉得，因为它太肮脏了或者什么或者什么。好吧，有时人们会开我们五年前开过的同一个笑话。所以我们的事实核查员，我们有一个，你知道，一小群很棒的事实核查员，不仅检查文章，而且，你知道，真正深入挖掘事实，他们也检查漫画，一是为了确保我们以前没有开过这个笑话，二是它准确。是的，想象一下准确性，在笑话写作和幽默中。如果它不准确，你显然会和艺术家合作，他们想这样做吗？他们想说，你知道，帝国大厦只有100英尺高
that you were, that you regret that you're like, Oh, it was so, is whenever stuck out to you that you thought because it's too filthy or something or something or whatever. Well, sometimes people make the same joke that we had five years ago. So our fact checkers, and we have a, you know, a small army of wonderful fact checkers, not only check the articles and for, you know, really drill down on the facts, but they also check cartoons, one to make sure we haven't made this joke before, two that it's accurate. Yeah, imagine that accuracy and in joke writing in humor. And if it's inaccurate, you obviously you work with the artist and do they want to do that? Do they want to say that the, you know, the Empire State Building is only 100 feet tall
或者无论什么。所以你想去那里。而且，但他们就像，我不知道，我开始认为漫画就像小手榴弹，要么它们，要么它们爆炸，要么它们不爆炸。好吧，但还有，还有它的文化手榴弹，你发现自己被夹在中间，一方面是潜在的感知压力，要求讽刺基于某种觉醒，这，你知道，人们可以提出一个论点，即《纽约客》的左倾基础会要求，而另一方面来自另一边的压力说，好吧，你们这些家伙在这里走得太远了。你甚至不想让我们再读这本杂志了。就像它不会经常出现在漫画里。我认为你在政治争论中看到更多。
or whatever. But so you want to get there. And, but they're like, I don't know, I've kind of come to think of cartoons as like little hand grenades, either they, either they blow up or they don't. Well, but there's also, there's also the cultural hand grenade of it that you find yourself caught in between the potential perceived pressure on one side to have the, the satire be based in sort of wokeness, which, which, you know, one could make an argument that, that the left leaning base of the New Yorker would demand versus the pressure from the other side saying, well, you guys are getting too far over here. You don't even want us to read the magazine anymore. Like it doesn't come in cartoons all that often. I think that you see that more in political argument.
是的。而且我认为，它，它不是左，右，而是自由，左，你知道，激进。明白了。至少在这些区域，那是，那是你看到，看到关注的地方。我不是指《纽约客》。我只是指整体。是的。不，那是现在真正的战斗所在。所以你们在多大程度上回应？你们是否意识到社交媒体和回应？因为现在回应太直接了，而且经常充满尖刻。是的。这在多大程度上驱动或引导你们所做的事情或你们对此有多了解？多少？这是一个困境。是的。这是一个困境，因为一方面，我一生中做了两个非常好的决定。对我来说，一个是娶我的妻子，我和她结婚30年了，似乎没有尽头
Yeah. And I think it's, it's less left, right, as it is liberal, left, you know, radical as well. Gotcha. At least in these precincts, that's, that's where you see the, see the attention. I don't mean just the New Yorker. I just mean overall. Yeah. No, that's where the real battle is now. So to what degree do you guys respond to? Are you aware of social media and response? Because now the response is so immediate and so often filled with vitriol. Yeah. To what degree does that drive or steer what you guys do or how aware of it? How much of that? It's a dilemma. Yeah. It's a dilemma because on the one hand, I've made two really good decisions in my life. For me, one was to marry my wife, who I'm married to for 30 years and there seems to be no end in
在视线中，除了，你知道，死亡率。然后另一个是，她在之后。我们要问她同样的问题。顺便说一句，她不同意。你应该收听。我们要反驳。然后她会有反驳。第二件事是没有注册Twitter，因为人们在，我不知道你们，但人们在像我这样的工作中，无论他们是在经营《纽约时报》还是《大西洋月刊》或《华盛顿邮报》或小杂志，无论是什么，他们做两件事之一。要么他们很快变得令人难以置信的无聊，说，我们有一篇关于这个的非常好的文章，然后我们有一篇非常好的，它变成了促销，然后没人关心。或者有人在Twitter上对他们说了什么让他们生气的事情。
sight except for the, you know, mortality. And then the other one is, she's on after this. We're going to ask her the same question. She disagrees, by the way. You should tune in. We're going to rebuttal. And then she will have a rebuttal. And the second thing was not to sign up for Twitter because people in, I don't know about you, but people in jobs like mine, whether they're running the New York Times or the Atlantic or the Washington Post or small mag, whatever it is, they do one of two things. Either they quickly become unbelievably boring and say, we had a really good piece about this, then we had a really good, it becomes promotional, and then nobody gives a damn. Or somebody tweets at them something that pisses them off.
而在凌晨两点，喝了几杯啤酒或无论什么之后，他们的乐趣是他们决定变得诚实。那是一场灾难。那是一场灾难。我也见过这种情况发生。所以当然我看着Twitter，就像吉米·斯图尔特在《后窗》中看着他的邻居一样。我潜伏，因为它很有趣。如果那里有，那是杰森的举动。我听说过。你的发行量在增长吗？你注意到像印刷和社交媒体上的一切吗？所以这就是我们的业务发生的事情。杂志业务和《纽约客》的业务过去主要是广告。然后世界上发生了一些事情。而且它
And at two o'clock in the morning, after having a couple of beers or whatever, their pleasure is they decide to become honest. And that's a disaster. That's a disaster. And I've seen that happen too. So of course I look at Twitter in the same way that Jimmy Stewart looked at his neighbor in rear window. I lurk because it's interesting. And if there is, that's Jason's move. I've heard that. Do you have a circulation growing? Do you notice like over everything print and social? So here's what's happened to our business. The magazine business and the New Yorkers business used to be predominantly by a huge majority advertising. And then something happened in the world. And it's
与我们刚才谈论的有关。谷歌和Facebook特别占据了世界上所有的广告，比如75%。所以如果你看1967年的一期《纽约客》，它充满了广告，有些产品甚至不存在了。它充满了广告。如果你现在看印刷杂志，它少得多。所以你会看着它说，好吧，他们到底是怎么存在的？我们存在是因为我们下注了。赌注是，在过去，你支付订阅的费用是一笔微不足道的钱。赌注是，谢天谢地，它成功了，我们基本上对读者说，你需要支付更合理的价格。每周一次像星巴克的一小杯咖啡怎么样？所以一年150美元。
related to what we're just talking about. Google and Facebook in particular took up all the advertising in the world, like 75% of it. So if you look at an issue of the New Yorker from 1967, it's fat with ads for products that some of most don't even exist anymore. It was fat with ads. If you look at the print magazine now, it's far less. So you would look at that and say, well, how the hell do they exist? We exist because we made a bet. And the bet was in the old days, what you paid to subscribe was a trivial amount of money. The bet was, and thank God it worked out, is we basically said to the reader, you need to pay a more reasonable price. How about as much as a small cup of coffee at Starbucks once a week? So $150 a year.
对。而且我们的读者，谢天谢地，足够爱《纽约客》，所以他们这样做了，所以我们做得还可以。我的意思是，它不是Facebook。它不是谷歌。你还在做很多插页吗……是的，但是大多数，你这样做，但大多数人显然是在数字订阅。什么是插页？抱歉，这是在杂志业务中。大卫和我都知道。抱歉，是的。小卡片，从印刷杂志里掉出来的东西。不是你想的那样。只是一个小……大卫，我的意思是，你永远不会说这个，但我会说。我的意思是，你在山顶。你觉得你的工作会去哪里？我的意思是，你会一直待在那里直到你死吗？我的意思是，你不能……有什么比成为
Right. And our readers, thank God, love the New Yorker enough so that they did this and so that we're doing okay. I mean, it ain't Facebook. It's not Google. Do you still do a lot of blow-ins on the... Yeah, but most, you do that, but most people are subscribing, obviously, digitally. What are blow-ins? Sorry, it's in the magazine business. David and I know. Sorry, yeah. Little cards, the things that fall out of the print magazine. It's not what you think. Just a little... David, I mean, you would never say this, but I'll say it. I mean, you're at the top of the mountain. Where do you see yourself going with a job? I mean, would you just stay there till you die? I mean, you couldn't... What could be better than being
《纽约客》的编辑更好？耶稣基督，宝贝。好吧，我的意思是，我只是……你在问我关于死亡的事吗？今天早上别让他面对他的死亡率。不，但你之后想做什么？有什么比这更好的吗？什么？你知道……我是在谈论Smartless播客。没错。成为《纽约客》的编辑是山顶。A，风景如何？B，在这之后你还能做什么？在这之后你想做什么？好吧，对于大多数编辑来说不寻常，我是通过写作来到这里的。换句话说，
the editor of the New Yorker? Jesus Christ, baby. Well, I mean, I just... You're asking me about death? Don't make him face his mortality this morning. No, but what do you want to do after this? What could be better than this? What? You know... And I'm speaking about the smartless podcast. That's right. Being the editor of the New Yorker is the top of the mountain. A, how's the view? And B, what could you ever do after this? What would you want to do after this? Well, unusual for most editors, I came to this through writing. In other words,
我在《华盛顿邮报》工作了五、六年之后，我是《纽约客》的作家。编辑是蒂娜·布朗。有一天，她辞职去办另一本杂志，《Talk》杂志。谈论烟花。无论如何，我们不会进入那个。我确实和蒂娜相处得非常好。我认为她是一个杰出的人才和人。我于1998年成为编辑。我记得我和我妻子的谈话。她说，好吧，如果几年后不行，你就辞职回去写作。所以不是几年。但在某个时候，如果我还有……我的大脑没有炒鸡蛋，我会再写。而且我62岁了。我不应该永远待在那里。
I was a writer at the New Yorker after being at the Washington Post for five, six years. The editor was Tina Brown. One fine day, she quit to go off to do another magazine, talk magazine. Talking about fireworks. Anyway, we won't get into that. And I really got and do get along exceptionally well with Tina. I think she's an exceptional talent and person. And I became editor in 1998. And I remember the conversation I had with my wife. She said, well, if it doesn't work out after a couple of years, you just quit and go back to writing. So it wasn't a couple of years. But at some point, if I still have... I don't have scrambled eggs for a brain, I'll write again. And I'm 62 years old. I shouldn't stay there forever.
《纽约客》在60年代、70年代和80年代的伟大编辑是威廉·肖恩。但他一直坚持到快80岁。我不确定那是个好主意。我很乐意看到你接替查理·罗斯。我过去常常喜欢……这就是我第一次开始爱上你的原因。只是看着你们过去进行的那些伟大的对话。我很怀念他的节目。我很乐意看到像你这样的人接替那个。我想看到你接替杰森在Smartless上的位置。大卫，大卫，我正要说，所以你赢了……你不仅是一位作家，你还是一位享有相当声誉的作家。我忘了告诉你你写的书，
The great editor of the New Yorker in the 60s, 70s and into the 80s was William Shawn. But he kept at it until he was almost 80. And I'm not sure that's a brilliant idea. I'd love to see you take over for Charlie Rose. I used to love... That's why I first started falling in love with you. Just watching those great conversations you guys used to have. And I miss his show. And I'd love to see somebody like you take over for that. I'd like to see you take over for Jason on spotless. David, David, I was going to say, so you win... Not only were you a writer, you're a writer with a considerable acclaim. And I forget to tell your book that you wrote,
你赢得了普利策奖，是……《列宁的墓》。《列宁的墓》。它是关于苏联解体的。对。《列宁的墓》。然后你成为了《纽约客》的编辑。当然，这是一个档位转换。是的。这是一个巨大的档位转换，去……这有点像从演员到导演，杰森非常了解这一点。你保持在同一个学科内，如果你愿意的话，但你从不同的角度看它。好吧，是其他人。是其他人。换句话说，作家……我想为《纽约客》的作家创造的是一种天堂。换句话说，
that you won the Bullets or Four, was it... Lenin's Tomb. Lenin's Tomb. It was about the collapse of the Soviet Union. Right. Lenin's Tomb. And then you become an editor at the New Yorker. It's a gear shift, of course. It is. It's a massive gear shift to go... It's kind of like going from actor to director, which Jason knows all too well. You're staying within the same discipline, if you will, but you're looking at it from a different perspective. Well, it's other people. It's other people. In other words, a writer... What I want to create for writers at the New Yorker is a kind of paradise. In other words,
他们知道他们在谋生，但同样重要的是，他们有自由去探索他们想探索的东西，并在适当的时候有时间去做。这在报纸上是不可能的。在报纸上，你经常被分配到X或……我就是。而且我在那里待了10年，非常快乐。我的最后一个任务是人间天堂，意思是莫斯科。但我希望在《纽约客》，人们永远、永远、永远不要做让他们感到无聊或他们不感兴趣的事情。在莫斯科，随着戈尔巴乔夫的倒台，然后进入叶利钦等等，那些最后几天是什么样的？那是什么样的？只是作为一个观察者，甚至不仅仅是从新闻的角度，只是观察
that they know they're making a living, but equally important that they have the freedom to explore the things that they want to explore and have the time to do it where that's appropriate. And that's not the case at a newspaper. At a newspaper, you're assigned very often to X or... And I was. And I was perfectly happy at it for 10 years. And my last assignment was Heaven on Earth, meaning Moscow. But I want at the New Yorker people never, ever, ever to be working on something that bores them or they're not interested in. What were those last days like in Moscow, as it fell with Gorbachev and then going into Yeltsin and all that stuff? What was that like? Just sort of as an observant, not even just from a news standpoint, just sort of watching
他们不仅知道自己能以此谋生，同样重要的是，他们有自由去探索自己想探索的事物，并在适当的时候有时间去做这些事。但在报社情况并非如此。在报社，你经常被指派去写某某内容……我就是这样。我在那里待了十年，非常开心。我最后的任务是“人间天堂”，也就是莫斯科。但我希望在《纽约客》，人们永远、永远、永远不要去做那些让他们感到无聊或不感兴趣的事情。在莫斯科的最后日子是什么样的？当时戈尔巴乔夫倒台，接着是叶利钦上台等等。那是什么样的体验？仅仅作为一个观察者，甚至不仅仅是从新闻的角度，只是那样看着。
that whole shift. You know, I've never been a war correspondent. And war correspondence, when you ask them that, you know you're never getting a full answer because there's so much tragedy and horror and fear and peril involved. They never can... Unless they're writing their fullest book and from their fullest soul, they never get a full picture. I can answer your question because really, it was a revolution in which... I mean, there were people who died in certain incidents in Georgia and Azerbaijan and certain areas. But you know, even the coup that ended the whole thing in August of 1991, three people were killed. I mean, which is a tragedy for them and their families and everybody they know. But how often does that happen? It was, to answer
那种转变。你知道，我从来没当过战地记者。当你问战地记者这个问题时，你知道你永远得不到完整的答案，因为其中涉及太多的悲剧、恐怖、恐惧和危险。他们永远无法……除非他们是在写他们最完整的书，出自他们最完整的灵魂，否则他们永远无法得到全貌。我可以回答你的问题，因为那确实是一场革命，其中……我的意思是，在格鲁吉亚、阿塞拜疆和某些地区确实有人在某些事件中丧生。但你知道，即使是1991年8月结束这一切的那场政变，也只有三个人丧生。我的意思是，这对他们和他们的家人以及所有认识他们的人来说都是一场悲剧。但这种情况发生的频率有多高呢？回答你的问题，那真是
your question, thrilling. My wife and I lived in a tiny, crappy apartment and we worked from nine in the morning. She for the New York Times, me for the Washington Post from nine in the morning till two in the morning every day for four years and never regretted a second of it. And even on the rare moments when we went out of the country and we're on kind of relative vacation, we missed it and couldn't wait to get back. How drunk was everybody? Well, here's the thing. So I'm a Jew, you might possibly guess this. And so I found myself, you know, at these occasions, pouring the vodka into the potted plants half the time, because I can't keep up. I can't do it. I can't do it. And we will be right back. All right, back to the show.
令人兴奋。我和我妻子住在一个又小又破的公寓里，我们每天从早上九点开始工作。她为《纽约时报》工作，我为《华盛顿邮报》工作，每天从早上九点一直工作到凌晨两点，持续了四年，我一秒钟都没有后悔过。即使在我们难得离开这个国家去度假的时候，我们也想念它，迫不及待地想回来。大家喝得有多醉？嗯，是这样的。我是一个犹太人，你可能猜到了。所以我发现自己，你知道，在这些场合，有一半的时间都在把伏特加倒进盆栽里，因为我跟不上。我做不到。我做不到。我们马上回来。好了，回到节目。
Wait, back to the New Yorker. Do you have a favorite interview of all the time that you've ever done? Well, I mean, they've ranged from Howard Stern to Alexander Gosolzhenitsyn to ... I occasionally get a chance still to write pieces. And I've been on a streak of writing about older musicians. And right before the election in 2016, a friend of mine was friends in California with Leonard Cohn, who I really admired. And he said, do you want to meet Leonard? And I flew out to LA. We met. We talked for five hours. He's the most unbelievably eloquent, prolific, charming man. Great Canadian. A great Montrealer, yes. Great Montrealer. And so I asked to interview him. And you know, usually these profiles, and you've been through this process, usually these profiles,
等等，回到《纽约客》。你有没有最喜欢的一次采访？嗯，我的意思是，采访对象从霍华德·斯特恩到亚历山大·索尔仁尼琴，再到……我偶尔还有机会写文章。我最近一直在写关于老音乐家的文章。2016年大选前夕，我在加州的一个朋友和莱昂纳德·科恩是朋友，我非常钦佩他。他说，你想见见莱昂纳德吗？我飞到了洛杉矶。我们见面了。我们聊了五个小时。他是最令人难以置信的雄辩、多产、迷人的男人。伟大的加拿大人。伟大的蒙特利尔人，是的。伟大的蒙特利尔人。所以我请求采访他。你知道，通常这些人物专访，你也经历过这个过程，通常这些人物专访，
when they're not just junket things, you're spending a lot of time with them. You're going to this, you're seeing that. By this time, Leonard was in his 80s, and he was frankly dying. He had a number of illnesses, and he knew what was up. And so all this piece involved, which ended up being, I don't know, 10,000 words, which is long, was sitting there for two days and asking him questions for five, six hours each time, including a moment on the second day when he was furious with me and my friend, because we screwed up the time and we were late or whatever happened. And he accused us of torturing a dying man, which is not what you want to hear from Leonard Cohn. You really don't. Doesn't yield a lot of open answers. No, I felt terrible. But I just found him to be a person of
当它们不仅仅是公关活动时，你会花很多时间和他们在一起。你会去参加这个，你会看到那个。到那时，莱昂纳德已经80多岁了，坦率地说，他快要去世了。他患有多种疾病，他知道情况如何。所以这篇最终长达一万字的文章，涉及的内容就是坐在那里两天，每次问他五个、六个小时的问题，包括第二天有一个时刻，他对我朋友和我非常愤怒，因为我们搞砸了时间，我们迟到了或者发生了什么事。他指责我们折磨一个垂死的人，这不是你想从莱昂纳德·科恩那里听到的。你真的不想。这得不到很多开放的答案。不，我感觉糟透了。但我发现他是一个
really profound depth and wit and learning. And I don't know how he managed with all the women, because he was easily the most charming person I ever met, ever, ever. Well, how do you do it? Yeah. Well, yeah, David, you're just getting to know me, but I suspect that there's going to be a 200,000 word. I'm feeling it. Yeah. David, what is the dumbest thing that you enjoy doing every day or every week? Or is it a crappy reality show? Is it? I watch more TV than I'm really willing to admit right here. And you still get time to read and everything like that? I mean, yeah, it's to my advantage that I don't sleep very well. What's your guilty pleasure that people would be surprised to hear about? I just watched one of these, you know, there's all these Nordic
非常有深度、机智和学识的人。我不知道他是怎么应付那么多女人的，因为他绝对是我见过最迷人的人，真的，真的。嗯，你是怎么做到的？是的。嗯，是的，大卫，你才刚开始了解我，但我怀疑会有二十万字。我有这种感觉。是的。大卫，你每天或每周做的最蠢但又乐在其中的事情是什么？还是什么烂俗的真人秀？是吗？我看的电视比我愿意在这里承认的要多。你还有时间读书之类的吗？我的意思是，是的，我不怎么睡觉对我来说是有利的。你有什么人们会感到惊讶的罪恶快感吗？我刚看了这些，你知道，有很多北欧
thrillers and some of them are really good, right? Some of them are really good. There's also some that are incredibly boring. I mean, so this one, this one was set in Iceland. I don't even remember. And it wasn't even in Reykjavik. It was so boring. It was like a bad town of the fjord or whatever. I know the one you're talking about. I couldn't follow a thing. And yet I, I, I, it was just having to watch it because it was like, I don't. But that's still you watching something highbrow. I'm talking about. That wasn't the stupid ass thing that you did. No, no, this is highbrow to him. It's highbrow to him. Sorry, David. Keep going. No, I, I'll tell you. And, you know, I also, for my sins, we do a podcast called the New Yorker radio hour. And which I find enormously fun.
惊悚片，其中一些真的很好，对吧？其中一些真的很好。也有一些非常无聊。我的意思是，这一部，这一部背景是在冰岛。我甚至不记得了。它甚至不在雷克雅未克。它太无聊了。就像峡湾里的一个烂镇什么的。我知道你在说哪一部。我什么都看不懂。然而我，我，我，我不得不看，因为就像，我不知道。但那仍然是你看了些高雅的东西。我说的是。那不是你做的蠢事。不，不，这对他来说是高雅的。这对他来说是高雅的。抱歉，大卫。继续。不，我，我会告诉你。而且，你知道，我也因为我的罪过，我们做了一个叫《纽约客》广播节目的播客。我觉得非常有趣。
But I have such a hard time sleeping late at night. What I do is I find the most boring podcast I possibly can. And that's it. 10 minutes. You're welcome. Please say it's us. Please say it's us. Please say it's us. No, it's not. I promise you. Could you make a commitment today to write a hit piece on Sean and Jason? Can you just like a real, I want one of these real hit pieces that just takes them apart. Take them down, take them right down, right down to the studs. I want to ask you guys something. You guys have all had reporters come to you. When, when a reporter approaches you, is it like when a mountain lion approaches you on a walk through the hills of LA or how much trepidation is it? I have to tell you, I figure it took me years and years to figure this out.
但我晚上很难入睡。我所做的是找到我能找到的最无聊的播客。就是这样。10分钟。不客气。请说是我们。请说是我们。请说是我们。不，不是。我向你保证。你今天能承诺写一篇关于肖恩和杰森的抨击文章吗？你能像，我想要一篇这种真正的抨击文章，把他们拆解开来。把他们打倒，把他们彻底打倒，打倒在地基上。我想问你们一件事。你们都遇到过记者来找你们。当，当记者接近你时，就像山狮在洛杉矶的山丘上散步时接近你一样吗？或者有多少不安？我必须告诉你，我想我花了好几年才弄明白这一点。
But a lot of times journalists will, whether it's on camera or print or whatever, they'll ask you a question they know is a little racier that you don't want to go there. You don't want to answer. And I finally learned this tactic they do. They'll ask you a question and then they'll, they'll wait and they'll let you fill the awkward space. It's the oldest trick in the book, right? That's Howard. That's Howard. I told Howard that Howard Stern does the very thing. The first time I did Howard Stern, I go in there and I go, I figured out Howard, what you do is he, he, it's a rope-a-dope, right? So he brings up stupid thing. You get into dumb conversations about whatever it is. Right. It's like a analysis. Right. And then what he does is then he says,
但很多时候记者会，无论是在镜头前还是印刷品上，他们会问你一个他们知道有点刺激的问题，你不想去碰。你不想回答。我终于学会了他们用的这个策略。他们会问你一个问题，然后他们会，他们会等待，他们会让你填补尴尬的空白。这是书中最古老的把戏，对吧？那是霍华德。那是霍华德。我告诉霍华德，霍华德·斯特恩就是这么做的。我第一次做霍华德·斯特恩节目时，我进去，我说，我弄明白了霍华德，你做的是，他，他，这是一个绳索把戏，对吧？所以他提出愚蠢的事情。你陷入关于任何事情的愚蠢对话中。对。这就像一种分析。对。然后他做的是，然后他说，
and yeah, of course, somebody will bring it up and he'll say, and yeah, and you had an awkward thing with the police. Right. And you go, and there's a positive. He goes, and he says, go ahead. And suggesting that you had brought it up. He's changed. He's changed. I agree. But, but, but, but what I learned from, what I learned was then just to have a staring contest. Now I don't answer until they keep going. Yeah. Did you win? I just, I'm just completely quiet. Must be a great piece that resulted from that. Yeah. Absolutely. It's about a page. Like Zen Boon. It's got 20 words. You know what's annoying that reporters do? And it's generally not print reporters because they're, they're much more engaging in it. And they're looking for actual answers. But, but oftentimes
然后是的，当然，有人会提出来，他会说，然后是的，你和警察之间有一件尴尬的事情。对。然后你说，有一个肯定。他去，他说，继续。暗示是你提出来的。他变了。他变了。我同意。但是，但是，但是，但是我学到的是，然后只是进行一场凝视比赛。现在我不回答，直到他们继续。对。你赢了吗？我只是，我完全安静。由此产生的一定是一篇很棒的文章。对。绝对。大约一页。像禅宗公案。它有20个字。你知道记者做的一件烦人的事是什么吗？通常不是印刷媒体记者，因为他们，他们更投入。他们正在寻找实际的答案。但是，但是通常
you'll go, you'll do something. They'll say, they'll go, oh, so Lego movie. And there's no question. And I, and I started to get to the point where I just go, what, there's no question here. They'll go, or they'll go, that was fun. Yeah. Oh, the bestest in sports. And I experienced, I covered the, first of all, I want you to know, I was the Washington federal's correspondent for the Washington Post. So it was the USFL. Oh my God. And I was the second string boxing correspondent. Second string. But the, the, the, my favorite thing is, you know, you're in a locker room, which has kind of receded. Now it's much more formal and it's press conference. So you, but you just go in a locker room and the guys, you know, with the radio mics would just go,
你会去，你会做某事。他们会说，他们会说，哦，所以乐高大电影。没有问题。我，我开始达到那种地步，我只是说，什么，这里没有问题。他们会说，或者他们会说，那很有趣。对。哦，体育界最棒的。我经历过，我报道过，首先，我想让你知道，我是《华盛顿邮报》的华盛顿联邦队通讯员。所以那是USFL。天哪。我是二线拳击通讯员。二线。但是，但是，我最喜欢的事情是，你知道，你在更衣室里，这已经有点退缩了。现在更正式了，是新闻发布会。所以你，但你只是走进更衣室，那些家伙，你知道，拿着无线电麦克风的家伙只会说，
LeBron, that's shot. And then they'd extend, everybody would extend their arms with the microphone. But LeBron knew what to do. Yeah. Right. Yeah. And I was such an idiot that I would think I have to ask a really good question. And so I, I was covering the bullets as they were named now. They're now the wizards because bullets was not good with the murder rate in Washington at that time. That's true. What happened to that? And the best player on that team was Jeff Ruland, who, by the way, was not so good, but that's, that's what we had. And I said, you know, Ralph Samson is coming into the league. And how do you think Ralph Samson is going to be? Is he going to be a great NBA center? This was week two of the season, 82 games. He would not speak to me
勒布朗，那个投篮。然后他们会伸展，每个人都会伸出他们的手臂拿着麦克风。但勒布朗知道该怎么做。对。对。我真是个白痴，我以为我必须问一个非常好的问题。所以我，我当时在报道子弹队，就像他们现在被命名的一样。他们现在是奇才队，因为子弹队在当时华盛顿的谋杀率下不太好。那是真的。那发生了什么？那支球队最好的球员是杰夫·鲁兰，顺便说一句，他不是那么好，但这就是，这就是我们拥有的。我说，你知道，拉尔夫·桑普森要进入联盟了。你觉得拉尔夫·桑普森会怎么样？他会成为一名伟大的NBA中锋吗？这是赛季的第二周，82场比赛。他不会跟我说话
for the rest of the year. So good questions can, can, can screw you up. What's your sports passion now? Is it basketball? Basketball. I'm with, I'm with the Nets. The Nets. Yeah. The Nets are a great team, you know, in this new world of what's it called player empowerment, you know, in which everybody seeks, you know, the superstars all seek each other in this kind of new way of doing business. Well, the players decide where the dynasty is going to be. Well, and the agent, you know, we just ran a profile of, of Rich Paul, who's a LeBron's agent, and he's the pioneer in, in this. Yeah. Ask me what I'm thinking of right now. How about cupcakes, maybe, or just a bag of, fresh bag of cookies. Dr. Brown soda with a little cupcake. Sean, as soon as we're done,
一年剩下的时间。所以好的问题可以，可以搞砸你。你现在的体育热情是什么？是篮球吗？篮球。我和，我和篮网队在一起。篮网队。对。篮网队是一支伟大的球队，你知道，在这个所谓球员赋权的新世界里，你知道，每个人都在寻求，你知道，超级巨星们都以这种新的商业方式互相寻找。嗯，球员们决定王朝将在哪里。嗯，还有经纪人，你知道，我们刚刚刊登了一篇关于里奇·保罗的专访，他是勒布朗的经纪人，他是这方面的先驱。对。问问我现在在想什么。也许是纸杯蛋糕，或者只是一袋，新鲜的一袋饼干。布朗博士苏打水配一个小纸杯蛋糕。肖恩，我们一做完，
Sean is like, I know Sean, here's Sean's schedule for today. He's going to watch last night's hockey playoffs. Either he goes in the kitchen and he makes a tuna salad sandwich on white bread with chips, with plain chips on the side. Okay. So either does that. That's not a Jewish meal show. Or he orders food and he'll get in the car himself because he doesn't like other people grabbing his food and he'll go pick up. He won't do delivery. This is true. And he'll go and he'll get in the car sometimes and he drives close to where I live and I go, where are you going? It's like, you know, seven o'clock at night. He's like, I'm going to pick up dinner. I'm like, you know, they have postmates. He's like, no, no, no, no. And then you get, and then five o'clock is bowling
肖恩就像，我知道肖恩，这是肖恩今天的日程安排。他要看昨晚的冰球季后赛。要么他走进厨房，做一个白面包上的金枪鱼沙拉三明治，旁边放着薯片，原味薯片。好的。所以要么做那个。那不是犹太餐节目。或者他点餐，他会自己开车去，因为他不喜欢别人拿他的食物，他会去取。他不会送货。这是真的。他会去，他有时会开车，他开到离我住的地方很近，我说，你要去哪儿？就像，你知道，晚上七点。他说，我要去取晚餐。我说，你知道，他们有Postmates。他说，不，不，不，不。然后你得到，然后五点是保龄球
late. Can we go back to the part where you watch repeat hockey games? That's sarcasm. That is really, that is just desperation. Sean still thinks there's four quarters in a hockey game. Sean doesn't. I do, in fact, but Sean does not. I watch him. He pounces us out, you know. I couldn't, I just can't do it. Play by play, chalkboard play by play. David, we could hang out with you all day because you just, you make us feel better about ourselves. And I didn't get to half of my pre-written questions. I was so proud of the way I wrote them. What's your toughest one, Jason? They're all political and boring, but I just, I love you, your brain, your kindness, and all of that stuff. And I'd love to have you come back, please. This was really fun.
晚了。我们能回到你看重复冰球比赛的那部分吗？那是讽刺。那真的是，那只是绝望。肖恩仍然认为冰球比赛有四节。肖恩没有。我确实，事实上，但肖恩没有。我看着他。他扑向我们，你知道。我不能，我只是做不到。逐球，黑板逐球。大卫，我们可以整天和你在一起，因为你只是，你让我们对自己感觉更好。我还没讲完我预写问题的一半。我为我写它们的方式感到自豪。你最难的问题是什么，杰森？它们都是政治性的，很无聊，但我只是，我爱你，你的大脑，你的善良，所有这些东西。我很乐意让你回来，拜托。这真的很有趣。
David, for you, I pray that you never find yourself like in a social situation where Jason is stuck to you and he's hammering you with, and at first you're thinking, I'm talking to Jason Bateman. He's great from Ozark and stuff. And four minutes in, you're like, I will sever my own limbs off to get out of this fucking guy. Who doesn't think? Ozark's scared that shit out. Oh my God. I pray for you, David. We're doing the last season now. It's a musical, so it'll be young. Is it? It's really fun. It's a best time you watch. What a departure. We just made news right there. I think that's a great turn. There's a lot of fun bits. You can't live on plot alone.
大卫，为你，我祈祷你永远不会发现自己处于一种社交场合，杰森粘着你，他用……敲打你，起初你以为，我在和杰森·贝特曼说话。他演《黑钱胜地》之类的很棒。四分钟后，你会想，我会切断我自己的四肢来摆脱这个该死的家伙。谁不认为？《黑钱胜地》吓坏了。天哪。我为你祈祷，大卫。我们现在正在做最后一季。这是一个音乐剧，所以会很年轻。是吗？真的很有趣。这是你看过的最好的时间。多么大的背离。我们刚刚在那里发布了新闻。我认为这是一个伟大的转折。有很多有趣的片段。你不能只靠情节生活。
No. David, it was a pleasure meeting you. David, thank you so, so much. What a pleasure. Great to see you. Thank you, David, very much. Thanks, David. Bye, buddy. All right, man. Take care. Bye, buddy. Take care. Bye, bye. Oh, you know, I really, I really, I have so, I have so many questions for him. I feel like he could really solve a lot of, a lot of our issues. Why, why isn't somebody like that in charge? He's a smarty pass. Because he is in charge over there at the magazine. Because it's the most thankless thing to do now. Hey, but you know, we don't have to go on and on about this, but you know that thing about
不。大卫，很高兴见到你。大卫，非常非常感谢。真是荣幸。很高兴见到你。非常感谢你，大卫。谢谢，大卫。再见，伙计。好的，伙计。保重。再见，伙计。保重。再见，再见。哦，你知道，我真的，我真的，我有这么多，我有这么多问题要问他。我觉得他真的可以解决很多，很多我们的问题。为什么，为什么没有像那样的人负责？他是个聪明人。因为他在杂志社负责。因为现在这是最吃力不讨好的事情。嘿，但你知道，我们不必没完没了地谈论这个，但你知道关于
that when I said, it feels like there's nothing else we can do but vote. You know what I mean? Like that. He's like, no, there's more. There's tons of you to do. I just don't know that people know what to do or where to go or how to help. People just don't know and they want to. I mean, you know, he said art. I think he means graffiti. Yeah. Got a tag stuff. Yeah, just get in a tag. Let's start a tag crew. The three of us. You just have to turn your hat sideways a little bit, right? Dude, let me get my visor on. Yeah. I feel like it's all about penetrating those. Excuse me, excuse me, sir.
当我那样说时，感觉除了投票我们什么也做不了。你知道我的意思吗？就像那样。他说，不，还有更多。有很多你可以做的。我只是不知道人们知道该做什么或去哪里或如何帮助。人们只是不知道，他们想。我的意思是，你知道，他说艺术。我想他是指涂鸦。对。得标记东西。对，只是去标记。让我们组建一个标记团队。我们三个。你只需要把你的帽子稍微侧过来，对吧？伙计，让我戴上我的遮阳帽。对。我觉得这完全是关于渗透那些。对不起，对不起，先生。
It's about trying to get to the people that don't listen to facts or don't have access. I mean, I don't know. Yeah, I don't know. I think he's right though. It is like by people continuing to write, it is art. I mean, that seems to be the way that it always happens and through education. The most chilling thing he said to me was he said that at the end of it all, and if it doesn't work, then maybe we didn't deserve it. I know. I was like, oh, wow. Christ. And you know what? He's kind of right. Maybe we don't. And it's like we'll be dead by then. Well, yeah, it's like the idea that like, okay, well, you don't think that anybody deserves to. Well, you don't think that people should
这是关于试图接触那些不听事实或没有渠道的人。我的意思是，我不知道。对，我不知道。但我认为他是对的。这就像人们继续写作，这是艺术。我的意思是，这似乎是它总是发生的方式，通过教育。他对我说的最令人不寒而栗的话是，他说在这一切结束时，如果它不起作用，那么也许我们不配得到它。我知道。我当时想，哦，哇。天哪。你知道吗？他是对的。也许我们不配。就像到那时我们已经死了。嗯，是的，就像那种想法，好吧，好吧，你不认为任何人应该。嗯，你不认为人们应该
be taken care of and you don't be. And then ultimately that's going to be you that's not taken care of. Do you feel like this new family and you're in your old house is taking care of you? I got to see. I don't know. I don't know if I can call them family yet, but I do know that there's a lot of love down there. Oh boy. What about what about if you leave that your little sound booth right now, open up the door, you're going downstairs to say goodbye and everything. And they're all what if they'd like just got out of the shower and they all do the towel on or someone's on the couch is farting, watching TV. Like you don't want that to be the last vision of your house. People just, you know, almost literally peeing on the furniture.
被照顾，而你也不应该。最终那将是你没有被照顾。你觉得这个新家庭和你住在你的老房子里是在照顾你吗？我得看看。我不知道。我不知道我是否能称他们为家人，但我确实知道那里有很多爱。哦，男孩。如果当你现在离开你的小录音棚，打开门，你要下楼去告别什么的，那会怎么样？他们都像刚洗完澡，他们都披着毛巾，或者有人在沙发上放屁，看电视。就像你不想那是你房子的最后一个景象。人们只是，你知道，几乎字面上在家具上撒尿。
I mean, what are you going to sneak out of there? You know, listen, this, this is a nice, these are nice people. So what, what are you, what is the scene you're describing you're talking about? I just don't, why would you want your last image to be somebody else nesting in your place? Are you going to be all right with that? Not exactly. Well, it's not what I wanted, man. This is the situation I'm in. Well, Sean and I are doing it on a laptop. You don't need to be in your sound booth. This is where all my stuff is, dude. Guess what? You unplug the laptop. It is made to be portable. Here's the other thing, because I have to do, I have a lot of other voice commitments. So then I'm just, again, schlepping everything. Plug a mic into your laptop. And now I got to
我的意思是，你要从那里溜走吗？你知道，听着，这，这是好的，这些人是好人。所以你，你描述的场景是什么，你在说什么？我只是不，为什么你会想要你的最后一个形象是别人在你的地方筑巢？你会对此没问题吗？不完全是。嗯，这不是我想要的，伙计。这是我所处的境地。嗯，肖恩和我在笔记本电脑上做。你不需要在你的录音棚里。这是我所有东西所在的地方，伙计。猜猜怎么着？你拔掉笔记本电脑。它是为了便携而制造的。这是另一件事，因为我必须做，我还有很多其他的配音承诺。所以然后我只是，再次，拖着一切。把麦克风插到你的笔记本电脑上。现在我必须
go back and forth between here and where I'm currently living. I'm googling words that begin with bye. Are you? Oh my God, you're the worst. That's all you think about when we do our little post trap up. Are you going to win the bye competition? I know. You know what? You're banned for a week. Yeah, you're out. You're out. You can't call bye. You cannot call bye for a week, because you've just squalled up by yourself. Oh my God, I'll cry. Yeah, that's like using a computer for a crossword puzzle. Yeah. What are you doing? Yeah, you can't, too. Bye. What's the best one you came up with there, Sean? Which one are you excited about? Read them out, you dick. Bye, Laws, but that was B-Y-E. I used that one. Are you doing? Are we allowed
在我和我目前居住的地方之间来回奔波。我正在谷歌搜索以bye开头的单词。你是吗？天哪，你是最糟糕的。这就是我们做我们的小总结时你所想的一切。你要赢得再见比赛吗？我知道。你知道吗？你被禁赛一周。对，你出局了。你出局了。你不能说再见。你不能说再见一周，因为你刚刚自己搞砸了。天哪，我会哭的。对，那就像用电脑做填字游戏。对。你在做什么？对，你也不能。再见。肖恩，你想出的最好的一个是哪个？你对哪一个感到兴奋？读出来，你这个混蛋。再见，法律，但那是B-Y-E。我用了那个。你在做什么？我们被允许
to recycle? That's a question. No, you're not. And you know what else you're not allowed to do is fucking chew gum on a podcast. What are you doing? Sorry, I just put it back in when David- I know, I saw that. Oh, God, that was funny. Do you want to know what kind of gum I chew? No. Okay, then nobody will know. Great. Where'd it go? You just denied our listener from hearing what kind of gum I chew. Well, you know, if you chew it too hard, you might accidentally bite your cheek. Did I do it? Smart, Blast. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbako, Michael Grant Terry,
循环使用吗？这是一个问题。不，你不被允许。你知道你还不被允许做的是在播客上嚼口香糖。你在做什么？抱歉，我只是把它放回去，当大卫——我知道，我看到了。哦，天哪，那太搞笑了。你想知道我嚼什么口香糖吗？不。好吧，那没人会知道。太棒了。它去哪儿了？你刚刚拒绝了我们的听众听到我嚼什么口香糖。嗯，你知道，如果你嚼得太用力，你可能会不小心咬到你的脸颊。我做了吗？聪明，Blast。SmartLess是由Bennett Barbako、Michael Grant Terry和Rob O'Jurf 100%有机和手工制作的，
and Rob O'Jurf. Our next episode will be out in a week, wherever you listen to podcasts or you you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music, or early and add free by subscribing to Wondery Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondery app. Smart Loss There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
和Rob O'Jurf。我们的下一集将在下周播出，无论你在哪里收听播客，或者你现在就可以在Amazon Music上提前收听，或者通过订阅Apple Podcasts或Wondery应用程序中的Wondery Plus提前收听且无广告。Smart Loss 这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。